I quite fancy being a dip mat when I was
young and applied to the foreign office
and then I had a letter from the
ministry of Defense allegedly saying
there may be other jobs you'd find more
interesting please call this number
so I did and um then got involved in a
very long recruitment process
and 10 months later I found myself
walking through the front door of MI5 to
start work there as an intelligence
officer so in the UK there are three
main intelligence agencies first of all
is MI5 which is officially known as the
UK domestic Security Service which is
there to protect us against threats
within this country counter-espionage
counter-terrorism that sort of thing
there is MI6 which is officially known
as the secret intelligence service
that's the sort of James Bond foreign
intelligence agency and there's also the
government Communications Headquarters
gchq which is based down in Cheltenham
and that is the listening post it
eavesdrops on all of us